[Music]  my name is eric sean and i've been at  fox news for more than 25 years in 1995  i heard that we're gonna start a cable  channel and i was like man this is  exactly what i was hoping for borrowing  spreadsheets and financials we were  scrapping it was always us against the  status quo and we came to this  mission as a way of trying to you know  overturn the apple cart to be  real news people in a way that i don't  think the mainstream media told it the  search and rescue continuing i remember  when bill clinton got into trouble for  his fundraising and i asked president  clinton are you afraid you're going to  be indicted he looked at me and laughed  and go  you really do work for fox  it was a wonderful moment because it was  a question that would be on everybody's  mind but no one would want to ask it's  been an amazing incredible journey for  me personally and as a broadcast  journalist you can't get any better than  that  you